the 2018 hit Incredibles 2 was the
perfect sequel for our favorite
superhero family but Disney and Pixar
snuck in some moments that were
definitely not meant for kids so you
guys are closest I guess closer
check out these 10 Incredibles 2 moments
that only adults understand new math
every parent has like we felt like Bob
did when he tried to help - with his
homework that's nothing new kids have
been asking their parents for help with
their homework for decades and sometimes
it's just been too long since a parent
was in school for them to remember but -
his math homework is actually a joke
about something else entirely his
textbook says new math and Bob is so
frustrated because it's not the math he
learned he wonders why math needs to be
new and what's wrong with the old way
this is a joke about Common Core math a
few years ago almost every state in the
u.s. adopted the Common Core it's a set
of standards for learning it was
supposed to help make sure that kids all
over the United States are learning the
same things but for some reason Common
Core decided to change the way math was
taught there are all sorts of new
methods for basic math concepts but for
a lot of adults Common Core math makes
no sense change man plenty of people
think it's actually harder than the old
way Common Core gets a lot of criticism
for being too hard without a good reason
but lots of teachers say it's easier to
get kids to understand Incredibles 2 was
definitely making fun of Common Core
Shakespeare this next joke may not have
made every adult laugh but we bet lots
of teachers chuckled at violets joke at
the beginning of the movie violet was
really upset about having to watch Jack
Jack her whole family is fighting the
Underminer and she wants to help she is
standing in the parking lot outside the
track meet Tony who is supposed to take
violet to the movies on Friday sees her
her voice sounds familiar well duh they
had just had a conversation but then
violet throws off her superhero mask in
frustration remember in the world of The
Incredibles these tiny black masks hide
their true identity Tony realizes it's
violet when violet tries to make it
bright at school she tells him that she
was in a play she says it's Shakespeare
but they are trying to make it relevant
to the kids teachers everywhere struggle
with trying to make
really old literature interesting to
modern kids and Shakespeare with
superheroes does sound ridiculous
monkey throwing darts after the
incredible family defeats the under
minor things go really wrong all the
media shows is that the super has caused
a lot of destruction rick dicker drops
the family back off at their motel he
tells them that the government is
shutting down the program he is talking
about the government program that keeps
the supers hidden it is now illegal to
be a super but they don't get any help
keeping their identity a secret the
Super's wants the law to change but in
the u.s. laws are changed by congress
there is a line in the movie that says
we don't know about you but we certainly
wouldn't trust a monkey with darts this
joke was meant for the adults in the
audience it seems like no matter what is
going on adults love to complain about
congress or whatever government is in
their country it doesn't matter which
political party is in charge everyone
has their own opinion when it comes to
politics so the topic can be a little
heavy doesn't this sound like something
that an adult would say at Christmas
dinner
adolescence poor violet being a teenager
is hard enough but when you have secret
powers that are illegal it's even harder
violet spends the whole first movie with
a crush on Tony at the end of the movie
he asks her out but then he witnesses
her in her super form
rick dicker has to erase his memory and
he accidentally erases all memory of
violet violet is obviously really upset
she finally got her crush to ask her out
and now he has no clue who she is she
blames her dad because he told mr.
dicker she acts out a lot because she's
so upset she cries she pouts and she has
angry outbursts at one point - ask we
just know all the adults were laughing
at this line adolescents or puberty is
when all your body's hormones are going
crazy adolescents have wild mood swings
and did they just can't help it it's
biology but it is not the easiest time
to be a parent we could totally feel for
Bob in that scene and he tried to make
it right but if you ask us violet had a
pretty good reason to be upset she just
might have been a little calmer if she
wasn't in puberty United League of
Nations
unless you've been paying really close
attention in history class this joke
probably went right over your head in
credible stew Elastigirl meets
ambassador Henriette Selleck she
represents the uln and she is pro
superhero she wants to legalize them
across the world again when the
ambassador's plane is hijacked by scream
slaver Elastigirl saves her the
ambassador becomes even more outspoken
about restoring rights to supers so what
is the you LM this is the United League
of Nations the uln is not a thing in the
real world but it's a total history joke
in real life we have the United Nations
it's an organization that was founded
after World War Two ambassadors from
different countries work together for
peace but before the United Nations
there was another organization it was
called the League of Nations it was
formed after World War one and it failed
miserably some history buff picked the
name of the United League of Nations for
this movie it's not a joke everyone
would get but if your parents loved
history they probably thought it was
really clever we'd love that Incredibles
2 wasn't just goofy it has a lot of
smart jokes too adult beverages while
Elastigirl is away from home she
befriends Evelyn Dever unfortunately
Evelyn is this green slaver seriously
how did they not know this her name
literally sounds like evil endeavor
anyway
Evelyn and Helen are sitting together
one evening their voices are slurred
like they are under the influence of
something they are both holding small
glasses of dark liquid and we can
guarantee you that it isn't coke these
two ladies are drinking adult beverages
together we get it sometimes adults do
that but was it really necessary to
include in a kid's movie
surely they could have had the same
bonding experience over a nice glass of
juice Evelyn also really likes to
celebrate with adult drinks later in the
film she asks Elastigirl if she drinks
on the clock Elastigirl assures her that
she is definitely not on the clock why
couldn't they have had a slice of cake
or something instead they definitely had
way too much to drink their speech
wasn't clear and they were acting kind
of goofy this does not show responsible
drinking well how Pixar that just
doesn't seem like the best message to
send but we bet most kids didn't notice
do you think that's inappropriate keep
watching to find out the most
inappropriate joke in the movie John
Qwest your parents might not have caught
this next reference but we bet the
grandparents in the audience did - is
seen watching TV several times we
usually don't really know what he's
watching but at one point we can see the
whole screen there is some old-school
animation on the screen but this isn't
just a made-up cartoon this is footage
from an actual cartoon called
Jonny Quest Jonny Quest was about a ten
year old son of a government scientist
their family went on crazy adventures it
sounds awesome why haven't you ever
heard of this show well it only aired
for 26 episodes and it was on in the
1960s Wow that is basically forever ago
that is proof that the Incredibles
franchise takes place in the 1960s it's
a little hard to tell because of the
fictional technology but there are a lot
of things straight out of the 60s in the
movie ask your grandparents if they
remember the show Jonny Quest
we love that a modern animated movie has
such a cool throwback to old animation
and of course - would love an exciting
television show like that he's a super
force to be normal after all reflux
Winston never introduces Elastigirl to a
bunch of other supers like the PAR
family they have been forced into hiding
some haven't even gotten a chance to
really be a hero because of the law they
all really admire Elastigirl one of the
supers she meets is an old man he's
short and kind of looks like a frog and
his name is reflux they don't show his
power until later in the movie but
adults could figure it out pretty
quickly when you're an adult sometimes
your body doesn't work like it used to
one thing that happens is heartburn if
you eat too much spicy food your chest
literally feels like it's on fire this
is because of your stomach acid when the
acid goes up your esophagus
it's called reflux the Super's power is
basically throwing up acid reflux tells
Elastigirl that it's either a medical
condition or a superpower we're pretty
sure that it's usually a medical
condition that was so funny it was
hilarious seeing a little old man be a
super and since reflux is more common in
older people it was a perfect power but
it was still really gross
this is power only work if you eat spicy
food money talks many of the jokes and
Incredibles - are really subtle but
there are a ton of political messages
throughout the movie for over 15 years
superheroes have been in hiding forced
into it by a society no longer willing
support them and if you're an adult some
of them were really obvious there were
lots of comments about illegal still
being good members of society there are
jobs at the system being unfair
there was commentary about the roles
that moms and dads play but one of the
most obvious statements was said by
violets at the end of the movie
Elastigirl figures out that the screen
flavor is Evelyn the screen slavery
hypnotizes Elastigirl
mr. incredible and Frozone it's up to
violet - and Jack Jack to save the day
and they do then there is an awesome
superhero scene Elastigirl fights Evelyn
and the others stopped the ship from
crashing into the city Evelyn finally
gets caught her brother Winston is
shocked and disgusted but he's still
glad she's alive Evelyn gets arrested
and is going to jail violet yelled out
that Evelyn is rich so she probably
won't get more than a slap on the wrist
Wow it's sad but a lot of times rich
people don't get it as much trouble when
they break the law the writers were
definitely making a really obvious
statement about the justice system
violets wet issue Incredibles 2 has a
lot less inappropriate jokes about
bedroom humor if you know what we mean
in fact most of the adult humor was
really tamed even though it got
political but there was one line that
made lots of people uncomfortable Bob
tries really hard to make things right
with violet and Tony he feels bad for
Tony's memory getting erased he finds
out where Tony works and takes the
family there for dinner when Tony comes
up to the table to take their order
violet chokes on her water it goes
everywhere the poor girl is soaking wet
Oh embarrassing Bob keeps trying to
introduce violet to Tony and then he
says that she doesn't normally drift
like this whoa too far lots of people
did not think that joke was about water
it's about something way more
inappropriate and for violets dad just
say it makes it way worse if it was an
accident how did that line make it
through editing but if it wasn't what
was Pixar thinking adults everywhere
were made really uncomfortable by that
line it was just too much what do you
think was the funniest moment in
Incredibles 2 let us know in the
comments section for more super videos
click that big red subscribe button
thanks for watching and see you next
time on two things
[Music]